my Lords ladies and there's that life
betwixt tis evident
no sensation nor the passions possessed
Dominion never the mind of man which is
ruled instead by a reason sovereign of
all faculties it must needs be remarked
that the power of the Commonwealth
derive it not from the despotic 'el
acquisitions of conquerors but from that
covenant amongst men whereby they most
resembling the lobster farmington are we
doing this again lady tottington i'm so
happy to finally meet the real year
Malti I'm not gonna kiss your hand you
freak I'm more of a woman than you are
it's not what they was saying at the
Parisian Selim clock Me Amadeus don't
break the fourth wall I'm trying to make
a video about post-modernism
get out of my drawing-room 18th century
sexual deviance so much for the tolerant
jacobins reason power truth these are
the kinds of topics that I simply don't
care about unfortunately we have to talk
about them because of a guy named Jordan
Peterson - who's Jordan Peterson Wow
he's a psychology professor at the
University of Toronto who got famous for
sounding the alarm about how protecting
transgender people under Canadian human
rights law shall surely lead to
Stalinism since then he's been touring
North America as a celebrity lecturer
david brooks called him the most
influential public intellectual in the
western world at his self-help book 12
rules for life as a national and
international bestseller i'm starting to
think we may need to take this guy
seriously he's got a lot of fans on
youtube and i hope you guys are here
because i want to talk a lot of leftists
who have responded to peterson haven't
really engaged with his ideas very much
he's often caricatured avoided or talked
past as in the infamous BBC interview
where Kathy Newman keeps repeating back
very uncharitable interpretations of
everything he says so you were saying
that by and large women are too
agreeable to get the pay
I see so I'm saying that that's one
component you're saying that women
aren't intelligent enough to run these
taka no you just say murderers so to
provoke on you I mean you are provocate
I never say lightly they aren't right
that you hate to be compared to you're
saying that we should organize our
societies along the lines of the
lobsters I think that people watching
this it comes off as if leftists are
like afraid of his actual ideas but I'm
not afraid of his ideas I'm not afraid
of anything I just smoked a bunch of
[ __ ] PCP daddy so I spent the last
couple weeks listening to hours of
Peterson's lectures and podcasts and
reading his books and honestly I think I
get why people like him
clearly he has real talent as a public
speaker and as a kind of life coach his
book 12 rules for life echoes past
bestsellers like Stephen Covey's the
seven Habits of Highly Effective People
or Rick Warren's The Purpose Driven Life
the difference is that Peterson takes
basic self-help insights like take
responsibility for yourself don't envy
other people and he renews them with the
intellectual trappings of psychology
philosophy yogi and psychoanalysis and
Bible readings he's telling us a pretty
classic story life is suffering
happiness is not enough to sustain you
through suffering so you need a higher
purpose in your life but I knew that
already I learned it at the AAA meetings
I refused to go to these are like basic
insights of world philosophy and
religion but their insights that today's
youth apparently haven't heard before
I guess because not enough of them are
alcoholics or at any rate they haven't
heard them in a vocabulary that
connected with so do a lot of people
Peterson's ideas seem new and urgent and
I don't really object to any of the
self-help stuff loose of Peterson's fans
are young men and I mean someone has to
live the neckbeards into shape and if
Pearson can do that more power to them I
mean sometimes boys just need a daddy
and sometimes girls do too
but there's a big problem here and the
problem is that all this life coaching
is basically just a Trojan horse for a
reactionary political agenda Peterson
advocates and ethics of self-help not
merely as a guide to private life but as
a replacement for progressive politics
which he characterizes as totalitarian
and evil there's no comparison there now
and a trans activist is there why not
the philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy now
Peterson doesn't use the word
progressive politics because that
doesn't sound scary enough his new
scarier word is post now we have to be
careful not to confuse postmodern neo
Marxism with cultural Marxism the Nazi
conspiracy theory about Marxist
intellectuals plotting to destroy the
West surely this is not the same thing
as that right right
so look I genuinely do not think Jordan
Peterson is a fascist and you may quote
me on that but I am wondering if it's
not a fascist conspiracy theory about
Marxist intellectuals plotting to
destroy the West then what is postmodern
neo Marxism well JP that's what I'd like
to talk about so Jordan sorry dr.
Peterson professor daddy let's talk and
for once I'd like to actually treat this
discussion with the seriousness and
respect I think it deserves
[Music]
[Applause]
okay good temperature tell me the oil
would you daddy thanks daddy it's really
an honor to bathe with a public
intellectual of your stature you know I
never like to argue in the bath so I
want to start by telling you the things
I like about you the first thing is that
I think some of your criticisms of the
left the stifling of even slightly
different opinions the gratuitous
loathing of Western cultural monuments
the politics and resentment are within a
certain media or corner of academia
valid complaints I even made a video
about that a long time ago when I was a
different person oh god the dysphoria
please don't watch it but my worry is
that you're leaving an international
political backlash against what is a
very localized problem and I worry that
some of our society's most vulnerable
people could be hurt by that backlash
like fine you hate postmodern
intellectuals an overly sensitive
student activists but if your backlash
also targets gender equality LGBT
acceptance and civil rights that would
be bad right I also like that you tell
people how to live their lives I mean I
personally hate taking orders outside of
the bedroom
but clearly the sheep need a shepherd
and you've really stepped up with these
12 rules you know on the Left we don't
really tell people what to do we tell
them what not to do don't exploit the
workers do not do blackface I guess we
tell people what pronouns to use for
trans people but that's a pretty small
rule compared to some of your rules like
how to raise your children or what
okay to criticize things the last thing
I like is you talk about deep [ __ ] I was
watching a video where you and a couple
of zany goons we're talking about Plato
and Aristotle the meaning of life and I
thought huh on the Left we don't really
talk about that kind of thing all we
talk about is how society oppresses
people and that might not be enough
because people need to have a positive
purpose in life I mean personally I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm pretty happy to
say here are watching the same three
seasons of strangers with candy until I
die but other people like Dostoevsky
come you other white guys who talk about
lobsters they have this need to have
purpose in the face of suffering and
like not just complain about patriarchy
I guess is easier to not complain about
patriarchy when patriarchy isn't the
thing that's making you suffer but I do
think that an education that only
teaches people about oppression is
inadequate we spend four years teaching
undergraduates why capitalism is bad and
then we say well you're educated now
good luck getting a job under capitalism
by and that really kind of sucks but you
know I think that's a point that could
probably be made without comparing
transgender activism to Stalin if you
like this came across a little more
sarcastic than I intended
see this is what you've got to use a
firmer hand with me Peterson if you
don't establish dominance I'm just gonna
melt off they use all this to passion
language and I'm on the side of the
oppressed all of that posturing it does
nothing but mask the underlying drive to
power and I've just been starting to
review their curriculum for children
from kindergarten to grade eight it's
pure social justice post-modernism the
people who hold this doctrine just
radical postmodern communitarian option
the mixed racial identity or sexual
identity or gender identity or some kind
of group identity terminal
control the most long to mid-level
bureaucratic structures and many
governments as well but even in the
United States
[Music]
so you gotta give it to JP when he says
stand up straight with your shoulders
back he means that
so Jordan Peterson has succeeded largely
by drawing in audiences with fairly
popular opinions political correctness
often feels stifling student activists
are sometimes in articulate and
over-reactive
angry transsexuals are telling me what
words to use and I don't like it but
once he draws you in with these inviting
preludes he leads you to a pretty weird
place his central political message is
that leftist professors student
activists campus diversity initiatives
and corporate HR departments are
collectively following the philosophy of
postmodern neo Marxism to destroy
Western civilization and sink us all
into a totalitarian nightmare now
there's just no avoiding that this idea
is actually pretty similar to the
cultural Marxism or cultural Bolshevism
theory but I'm just gonna ignore that
because if I do well on it will sound
like I'm saying Peterson is a fascist
and then everyone will think I'm crazy
look I'm not afraid of psychologists I
don't like to hide so let's just try not
to think about that and instead
straightforwardly ask is it true that
postmodern neo Marxism is out to destroy
us all well why don't we analyze the
concept of postmodern and Marxism we all
know what Marxism is the idea that
society should be understood as a class
struggle between workers and capitalists
and that the workers will eventually
revolt some college professors
definitely do believe that but zero
percent of corporate HR departments do
so that okay so what is post-modernism
well it's the vaguest word in the
English language some people try to
explain it by listing all the things
that are called postmodern and then
trying to guess what they have in common
that's basically what the YouTuber
armored skeptic did in his video about
it so many daddies in this video we did
invite the model of barbecue complain
about post-modernism listen to some
Zeppelin I've had worse evenings I don't
think there really is a common thread
linking all the things called postmodern
basically post-modernism is everything
that happened after 1945 that seemed you
knew at the time but when Jordan
Peterson says post-modernism he's not
talking about Andy Warhol or Quentin
Tarantino he's talking about postmodern
philosophy so what's that well basically
it's a
scepticism not YouTube skepticism but
actual skepticism you know like having
doubts about whether humans can really
know things about the world how
skepticism is obviously not a new idea
that goes way back to ancient times but
more specifically post-modernism is
skepticism about modernism
so what's modernism what's what what are
words what's anything I'm gonna divide
modernism into two periods because I
feel like it first there's early
modernism early modernism is the
philosophy developed by a bunch of
boring eighteenth-century Queens which
says that we can form Universal theories
about the world through observation and
reasoning aka the scientific method now
that turns out to work pretty well for
whatever questions you have about plants
and crystals and how to medically
reconfigure human genitals but it has
some limits which was pointed out by
David Hume one of the least boring 18th
century Queens and one of the only
philosophers I can actually put up with
in small doses even though he was a
[ __ ] racist and also Scottish this is
a call out Hume argued that from Asher
to the empirical perspective you can't
really know much about important things
like morality causation and the self
because those aren't the kinds of things
you can observe anyway then the late
modernists came along and they said [ __ ]
him we're gonna do science about those
things anyway so the late modernists
were a bunch of boring
nineteenth-century neckbeards who one
way or another try to discover universal
scientific truths about humans so for
example you have psychoanalysis which
said human nature can be understood in
terms of unconscious tribes which is of
course ridiculous I'm conscious of all
my drives and you got Marxism with its
analysis of boot huazi and proletariat
you got early sociology and anthropology
which started out with recent social
evolutionism and progresses to a kind of
we're all the same universalism Jordan
Peterson is right at home with the lay
modernists his first book maps of
meaning is an attempt to describe how
humans make sense of the world and
create order out of chaos through
universal myths and archetypes which he
claims are a product of our species
evolutionary past
boy this is a lot of explaining it's so
much explaining it's triggering gender
dysphoria I better put on some longer
nails nails
it's an old woman who'd means to you
haha post-modernism is skepticism about
modernism
so whereas modernists try to create
eternal and universal theories about a
reality history and humanity post
modernists say actually no that's not
possible
for example the French post modernist
Michele fuku Sargon little Guth's
Michele fuku wrote intellectual
histories of subjects like psychiatry
medicine and criminal justice in which
he argued that we should not understand
these histories and straightforward
progressions toward liberty and
scientific truth but rather as mere
shifts in the way that power orders our
institutions and populations the other
post modernist I've actually read a lot
of his Richard Rorty yeah [ __ ] you
Derrida if you wanted me to read you you
should have been easier to read Rorty
advocates an attitude toward knowledge
he calls ayran ism irony being the
sceptical caution with which we should
regard our own beliefs in our awareness
that our vocabulary for describing and
understanding the world is not the final
or best vocabulary all right that's
enough explaining and my nails are done
check it out do you enjoy having long
glamorous nails with the lesbians and
queer girls keep flaring up them with
barely concealed visceral rage well I
have a solution for you the bisexual
manicure one end for the V one end for
the D both for degeneracy it's
absolutely filthy so we've got all the
pieces on the table now you've just got
up with a puzzle together on the one
hand we have Marxism a fundamentally
modernist worldview that theorizes the
human condition in economic terms on the
other hand we have post-modernism the
sceptical worldview that denies our
capacity to know any universal truths
about anything on the face of it it was
seeing these two ideas are not
compatible and there is an extensive
history of dispute between them with for
instance the Marxist Sartre calling
Foucault the last barricade the Fugazi
can erect against Marx and of course as
we all know when Foucault died
capitalism did and forever
[Music]
so where does Peterson get off talking
about postmodern neo Marxism well it's
true that a lot of post modernists were
in some way influenced by Marxism
so the phrase could just refer to that
continuity but that's not what Peterson
means it's clear for the way he uses the
term the concept is even more jumbled
and nonsensical than it initially
appears Peterson uses the term
postmodern neo Marxism to include not
only postmodern intellectuals and
Marxist intellectuals but also liberal
politicians academic administrators in
corporate HR departments that care about
diversity and so-called identity
politics activists including feminists
LGBTQ and civil rights activists
basically is the entirety of the modern
left now I've already mentioned how
Marxism and post-modernism more
fundamentally at odds since Marxism is a
big story about a struggle between two
clear and distinct groups and
post-modernism is skepticism about big
stories like this and about the
stability of binaries like booj Rossi
and proletarian but that's not the only
tension and Peterson's [ __ ] idea
of postmodern neo Marxism anyone with
any experience and leftist circles knows
that Marxists and identity politics
activists are constantly at each other's
throats because the Marxists accused the
activists of being blue jaw dogs who
want more female CEOs of color and more
disabled transgendered drunk pilots
while the activists accuse the Marxists
of being a boys club of brochure lists
no more work on gender and race issues
than the average Jordan Peterson found
most often these accusations are correct
because everyone is problematic and I
disown them all and then there's also
the conflict between the identity
politics activists and the post
modernists why does everyone think that
identity politics is postmodern there's
nothing postmodern about it identity
politics advocates for rights equality
and justice for particular groups such
as women people of color and gay and
trans people this kind of activism
presupposes that these group categories
exists and are a useful basis for
political organizing post modernists do
kind of the opposite they want to show
that these categories race gender sexual
orientation or contingent social
constructs and/or themselves potentially
oppressive this is why conventional
feminist activists often hate postmodern
feminism because the postmodern feminist
Swan
the whole concept of womanhood for
instance is contingent and potentially
oppressive and they think we should be
working to destabilize and under - and
then the conventional feminist activists
say the [ __ ] we need the concept of
womanhood to organize around women's
political interests how are we supposed
to do that if we undermine and
destabilize the concept of womanhood and
in turn the postmodern feminists say
well here's a quotation from Judith
Butler the most famous postmodern
feminist ever is it not a sign of
despair over public politics when
identity becomes its own policy bringing
with it those who would police it from
various sides and this is not a call to
return to silence or invisibility but
rather to make use of a category that
can be called into question made to
account for what it excludes if you take
the first part of that quote out of
context it almost sounds like something
Jordan Peterson could have said the
difference is that JP actually does
think we should return to silence and
invisibility or does he it's hard to
tell what he thinks more on that in a
moment I bring all this up to show that
one the idea of postmodern neo-marxist
identity politics as a unifying concept
of the left is nonsensical and to
identity politics is not this dogma that
must go unquestioned there were
sophisticated debates about this going
on within leftist academia but Jordan
Peterson either doesn't know that or
doesn't care he uses the term postmodern
neo Marxism to characterize the left of
the unified philosophical force bent on
destroying Western civilization when in
fact it's a bunch of bumbling buffoons
who can't stop squabbling with each
other over every goddamn little issue
the only reason I can think of that the
left would appear to be a unified
philosophical force is if you're so far
to the right that literally everyone who
supports the economic and social
advancement of disadvantaged groups
looks like one homogeneous enemy but is
that what Doron Peterson is saying that
he opposes all social progress for women
racial and sexual minorities well it's
difficult to say because while he spends
much of his time comparing activists for
these movements to 20th century mass
murderers he resists being pinned down
to any more specific position I was
maybe too harsh on Cathy knew
earlier she came out of the interview
looking bad but she had a tough job to
do
Peterson's rhetorical strategy involves
saying something that's more or less
uncontroversially true while at the same
time implying something controversial
for instance Jordan Peterson will make a
claim like there are biological
differences between men and women which
is obviously true but he'll say it in
the context of a conversation about the
under-representation of women and
garment which implies what exactly so
how do you respond to this well either
you fall into the trap of arguing
against the obviously true statement or
you have to guess at what he's implying
in response to which he can accuse you
of misrepresenting him which is exactly
what happened with the Kathy Newman
interview the most famous moment were
Peters and dozens is the notorious
lobster argument so he starts by saying
here's this idea that hierarchical
structures are a sociological construct
of the Western patriarchy and then he
goes on to say that lobsters exist in
hierarchies and lobsters predate Western
patriarchy by millions of years so
checkmate postmodern neo-marxists you're
saying that we should organize our
societies along the lines of the
lobsters I'm saying that it's inevitable
that there will be continuity in the way
that animals and human beings organizing
organize their structures the problem
with that is that no one has ever said
that every hierarchy is the product of
Western patriarchy this is such a
massive straw man that it overshadows
any uncharitable interpretation of
Peterson suggested by Kathy Newman in
this interview no one on the Left denies
that there are some natural hierarchies
even the anarchists whose whole thing is
abolishing hierarchies limit themselves
to the abolition of unjust hierarchies
no one wants to abolish lobster
hierarchies the hierarchies were
interested in are those of gender race
and economics within our own society to
which the lobster case as a complete non
sequitur I mean you could use Peterson's
lobster argument the same way he uses it
to justify literally any hierarchy or
Authority no matter how unjust it could
be an 18th century Republican arguing
against the monarchy and the monarch
could turn around and say well
hierarchies are inevitable god save the
lobster Queen
oh dear God my Lords ladies those lines
between present rumors and Republican
rumbling was amongst the rabble have
compared us to summoning together let us
remind you that Nature has SIL made
lobster but some individuals be stronger
than the others therefore let not the
power of our crustacean sovereignty be
any wise and pure and does for
parliamentarians well let them vote for
kick very good thank you
I need new roommates
so I've argued that Peterson is voting
the incoherent concept of postmodern in
Marxism that the supervillain in a
childishly simple worldview he's
promoting where these evil leftists are
out to destroy the West now it's time to
expect the other side of this coin what
exactly is the West well there's an
academic usage of the term the West that
describes the intellectual tradition
that runs from ancient Athens to
modern-day Europe and its colonies now a
true post modernist would want to
deconstruct the whole concept of the
West and show how the very idea is
racist and exclusionary and supremacist
and justify his imperialism and all that
kind of thing but we don't have time for
that right now so I'm just gonna grab
that the West is a thing and look at how
Jordan Peters and thinks about it for
Peterson the West seems to be equivalent
to capitalism individualism the idea
that each human has a spark of divinity
and he therefore equates it with
judeo-christian values a term more
popular with conservative pundits than
intellectual historians speeders and
contrasts judeo-christian values with
postmodern neo Marxism which he
describes as anti Western collectivist
relativist and totalitarian this framing
of a conflict of ideas in terms of
geographical chauvinism and external
threat is inaccurate and scaremongering
Marxism is Western philosophy
post-modernism is Western philosophy if
you're really concerned about preserving
the geographical boundaries of the
intellectual tradition you should be
ranting against the influence of
Buddhism likewise there is no feature of
SJW ideology that is meaningfully
non-western the very idea of people
requesting different pronouns to suit
their individual needs is exactly the
kind of thing a person who values
individual liberty over collective dogma
should be on board with could even argue
that Marxism is an extension of
enlightenment philosophy with its
concern for human progress science and
liberty I think a lot of people like
listening to Jordan Pederson talk about
the Western tradition but they don't
seem to like reading any of it
themselves if you did read it you'd find
a surprising diversity of thought that
doesn't reduce to judeo-christian values
much of Plato's
are concerned with arguing against
cultural relativism suggesting that far
from being an invention of the post
modernity it was actually a pretty
popular worldview among ancient Athenian
pederasts her favorite Enlightenment
philosopher David Hume famously said
that reason is and not only to be the
slave of the passions literally feels
over reals and meanwhile his
contemporary the Marquita solid was
advocating the abolition of morality
filling the churches with scat porn and
ushering in a reign of untethered sexual
perversion so decadent and depraved I'm
not even allowed to talk about it on
YouTube this is the Enlightenment not
post-modernism and it's just as much a
part of the West as Petersons soggy
Bible padding conservatism but again and
I really can't stress this enough I
don't care either way I make youtube
videos because I enjoy mood lighting and
set design so what do you people want
from me the lobster queen is dead long
live the Queen
[Music]
there is a day there's and I think you
would agree that there's just a
foundational erosion that I think people
of all sides and I think there's totally
intellectually smart people on the far
left that can help that where are those
people there's a there's a there's a
youtuber that I'm actually quite
interested in that I watch her type and
I don't mean the misgender Hercules I
think she has
contra points I don't know if you're
part of this of this youtuber who's on
the phone I've seen the name come up
every now and again I totally disagree
with everything this person says but I
look at it I'm like this seems very
reasonable educated academic and I saw
I'm seeing reasons to hope that everyone
hello Dave